how many of us have ever seen something
thought that we should report it but
decided not to and not that I need to
see a show of hands but I'm sure this
has happened to someone in this room
before
in fact when this question was asked to
a group of employees 46% of them
responded by saying that they had seen
something and decided not to report it
so if you raised your hand or quietly
raised your hand don't feel bad you're
not alone this message of if you see
something to say something it's really
all around us even when driving down the
highway you see billboards like this
encouraging us to report crime without
revealing ourselves but I still feel
like a lot of us are really
uncomfortable coming forward in the name
of the truth I'm an accounting professor
and I do fraud research and in my class
I encourage my students to come forward
with information if they see it or in
other words encouraging my students to
become whistleblowers but if I'm being
completely honest with myself I am
really conflicted with this message that
I'm sending to my students and here's
why whistleblowers are under attack
headline after headline shows us this
many people choose not to become
whistleblowers due to the fear of
retaliation from demotions
to death threats to job loss perpetual
job loss choosing to become a
whistleblower is an uphill battle
their loyalty becomes into question
their motives their trustworthiness so
how can I as a professor who really
cares about her students encourage them
to become whistleblowers when I know how
the world truly feels about them so one
day I was getting ready for my annual
whistleblower lecture with my students
and I was working on an article for
Forbes entitled Wells Fargo and
millennial whistleblowing what do we
tell them and now I was working on this
piece and reading about the case I
became outraged and what made me angry
was when I came to the fact and realized
that the employees that try to whistle
blow were actually fired
and it really made me think about the
message that I was sharing with my
students and it made me think what if my
students have been Wells Fargo employees
on the one hand if they whistle blew
they would got fired would have gotten
fired but on the other hand if they
didn't report the fraud that they knew
the way current regulation is written
employees are held responsible if they
knew something and didn't report it so
criminal prosecution is a real option
what's a person opposed to do with those
type of odds I of all people know the
valuable contributions that
whistleblowers make in fact most frauds
are discovered by them 42% of frauds are
discovered by whistleblower in
comparison to other methods like
management review and external audit and
when you think about some of the more
classic or historical fraud cases it
always is around a whistleblower [ __ ]
Watergate discovered by whistleblower
Vinc Enron discovered by whistleblower
and who can forget about Bernard Madoff
discovered by a whistleblower it takes a
tremendous amount of courage to come
forward in the name of the truth but
when we think about the term
whistleblower we often think of some
very descriptive words rat snake traitor
tattletale weasel and those are the nice
words the ones I could say from the
stage and so when I'm not in class I go
around the country and I interview
white-collar felons whistleblowers and
victims of fraud because really I'm
trying to understand what makes them
tick and to bring those experiences back
into the classroom but it's my
interviews with whistleblowers that
really stick with me and they stick with
me because they make me question my own
courage when given the opportunity what
I actually speak up and so this is a
couple of stories that I want to share
with you this is Mary Mary Willingham is
the whistleblower from the University of
North Carolina at Chapel Hill academic
fraud case and Mary was a learning
specialist at the University and she
worked with students primarily
student-athletes and what she noticed
when she was working with students is
they had they were turning in
on papers that seemed well beyond their
reading levels she started to ask a
couple questions and she found out that
there was a database where the
student-athletes could retrieve papers
and turned them in and then she found
out that some of her colleagues were
funneling students into fake classes
just to keep them eligible to play now
when Mary found this out she was
outraged and so what she tried to do was
go to her direct supervisor but they
didn't do anything and then marriage
tried to go to some internal university
administrators and they didn't do
anything so what happens when nobody
listens you blog so Mary decided to
develop a blog her blog went viral
within 4 to 24 hours and she was
contacted by a reporter now when she was
contacted by this reporter her identity
was known she was exposed and when she
was exposed
she received a demotion death threats
over collegiate sports Mary didn't do
anything wrong she didn't participate in
the fraud she really thought that she
was giving voice to students that were
voiceless
but her loyalty was questioned her
trustworthiness and her motives
now whistleblowing doesn't always have
to end in two motions or death threats
actually in 2002 this was the cover of
Time magazine where we were actually
honoring three brave whistleblowers for
their decision to come forward in the
name of the truth and when you look at
the research 22% of whistleblowers
actually report retaliation so there is
a huge population of people that report
and are not retaliated against and that
gives me hope so this is Kathy Kathy
Swanson is a retired city clerk from the
city of Dickson and one day Kathy was
during her job just like she always did
and she stumbled upon a pretty interest
in case see Kathy was at the end of the
month
and she was doing her treasurer's report
for the city and typically her boss Rita
Kronwall gave her a list of accounts and
said Kathy called the bank and get these
specific accounts and Kathy did her job
but this particular day Rita was out of
town and Kathy was busy she picks up the
phone
she calls the bank and says fax me all
of the accounts and when she gets the
fax she sees if there's an account that
has some withdrawals and deposits in it
that she did not know about it was an
account controlled only by Rita so Kathy
looked at the information she reported
it to her direct supervisor which was
then mayor Burke and this led into a
huge investigation a six-month
investigation come to find out Kathy's
boss Rita cron well was embezzling money
Rita was embezzling fifty three million
dollars over a 20-year period and Kathy
just happened to stumble upon it Kathy
is a hero and actually I had the
opportunity of interviewing Kathy for my
documentary all the Queen's horses and
Kathy wasn't seeking fame in fact she
really didn't want to talk to me for a
really long time but through strategic
stalking she ended up doing the
interview but she was seeking fairness
not fame and if it wasn't for Kathy
who's to say this fraud would have ever
been discovered so remember that Forbes
article I was talking about that I was
working on before my lecture well I
posted it and something really fantastic
happened I started receiving emails from
whistleblowers all over the world and as
I was receiving these emails and
responding back to them there was a
common theme in the message that I
received and this is what it was they
all said this I blew the whistle people
really hate me now I got fired but guess
what I would do it all over again if I
could and so as I kept reading this
message these all of these messages I
wanted to think what could I share with
my students and so I pulled it all
together and this is what I learned it's
important for us to cultivate hope
whistleblowers are hopeful despite
popular belief they're not all
disgruntled employees that have a beef
with the company their hopefulness
really is what drives them to come
forward we also have to cultivate
commitment whistleblowers are committed
and it's that passion to that
organization that makes them want to
come forward whistleblowers are humble
again they're not seeking fame but they
are see
fairness and we need to continue to
cultivate bravery whistleblowers are
brave Austin they didn't they
underestimated the impact whistleblowing
had on their family but what they
continued to comment on is how hard it
is to withhold the truth with that I
want to leave you with one additional
name Peter
Buxton Peter Buxton was a 27 year old
employee for the US Public Public Health
Service and he was he was hired to
interview people that had sexually
transmitted diseases and through the
course of his work he noticed a clinical
study that was going on within the
organization and it was a study that was
looking at the progression of untreated
syphilis and so there were 600
african-american males that were in this
study they were enticed into the study
through being given free medical exams
burial insurance and so what happened
through the course of this study is
penicillin was discovered to help treat
syphilis and what Peter noticed was the
participants in this study were not
given the penicillin to treat their
syphilis and the participants didn't
know so similar to Mary
Peter tried to report and talked to his
internal supervisors but no one listened
and so Peter thought this was completely
unfair and he tried to report again and
finally talked to a reporter very
similar to Mary and in 1972 this was the
front page of the New York Times
syphilis victims in us study went
untreated for 40 years this is known to
us today as a Tuskegee syphilis
experiment and Peter was the
whistleblower what happened to the 600
man you may wonder the 600 original men
28 men died from syphilis 100 died from
syphilis complications 40 wives were
infected and 10 children were born with
congenital syphilis who's to say what
these numbers would be if it wasn't for
the brave courageous act of Peter we're
all connected to Peter actually if you
know anybody that's in a clinical trial
the reason why we have informed consent
to
is because of Peters courageous act so
let me ask you a question that original
question a variation of the original
question how many of us have ever used
the term snitch rat tattletale snake
weasel leak anybody before you get the
urge to do that again I want you to
think a little bit it might be the Mary
the Peter the Kathy's of the world you
might be the person that could shape
history or they could be the person that
shapes yours thank you
[Applause]
[Music]